continue avec notre second débat on
prend du recul vous le savez on se
décale de l'actualité ce soir on parle
de ce tgv qui a tout changé c'était le
22 septembre 1981 françois mitterrand
inaugurait la première ligne à grande
vitesse qui m'était lyon à 2h40 de paris
depuis au gré des ouvertures de lignes
de tgv à a changé le visage de la france
exemple 1990 quand vendôme se retrouve
du jour au lendemain à trois quarts
d'heure de la capitale bilan deux
décennies plus tard avec jérôme ravier
il y à des hommes dont on peut dire
qu'ils ont changé le visage d'une ville
et jack bélanger fait partie de ceux là
en 1986 ce commerçant est un jeune
conseiller municipal de vendôme quand on
lui confie une mission un peu folle dont
il a gardé toutes les traces ici c'est
une partie des dossiers de fin 80 des
années 80 ce qui était fou c'était
d'essayer d'obtenir une gare tgv entre
paris et tours et qu'elle s'arrête à
vendôme et il a fallu mobiliser tous les
acteurs les élu es et nous avons créé
une association qui s'appelait vendôme
tgv qui a rassemblé tout ce qui était
favorable donc à la création de ces
dégâts sur le site nord de vendôme des
statuts de l'association à la cérémonie
d'inauguration de la gare jacques
bélanger a tout gardé et 31 ans après il
a toujours la même émotion en revoyant
ses souvenirs puisque la jeune
conseiller municipal de vendôme avec mon
père et conseiller général et comment
pour quoi on a bien fait de sonates et
là où il ya une volonté il ya peut-être
un chemin il faut se battre pour
l'obtenir
à quelques encablures du centre-ville la
gare de vendôme villiers sur loir et
créer plaçant la ville à 42 minutes de
la gare montparnasse contre 2h15 pour un
trajet en voiture
un formidable outil pour la ville qui a
pu attirer des entreprises ou des
travailleurs parisiens prêts à faire les
trajets quotidiens pour rejoindre la
capitale un legs dont se réjouit le
maire actuel
effectivement un très bel héritage
aujourd'hui c'est ses 800 passagers par
jour et puis ces cinq cent mille
voyageurs par an c'est une véritable
prouesse technologique qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de bénéficier d'entreprise
de renault qui peuvent grâce à sa faire
venir des salariés est en tout cas que
les salariés le cadre de vie que nous
avons en vendômois lvmh thales ou encore
sept compagnies d'assurance sont
installés à proximité de la gare ou un
vrai pôle d'activité a vu le jour avec
son lot d'emploi local et de retomber à
porter train de la capitale cette gare
tgv est un véritable atout d'un point de
vue économique évidemment mais pas
seulement en termes pratiques ça nous
permet de rejoindre très rapidement
paris d'un absence aussi de rejoindre
tour autrement que par la voiture chaque
jour ce sont huit allers retours qui
sont assurés une régularité qui ravit
les usagers vendômois je travaillais à
paris
tous les quinze jours pendant plusieurs
jours et je revenais ici est donc le tgv
est vital pour moi c'est pratique c'est
calme
1 45 minutes du bruit donc l'idéal 31
ans après sa sortie de terre la gare
s'est imposée comme la valeur ajoutée du
territoire vendômois le développement du
télétravail amène désormais une nouvelle
génération d'habitants cherchant le
charme de la campagne tout en conservant
l'accès à grande vitesse à paris
les 40 ans du tgv et son avenir on en
débat tout de suite j'accueille
françoise gatel bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes sénatrice d'ille-et-vilaine membres
du groupe union centriste président de
la délégation sénatoriale aux
collectivités locales et à la
décentralisation emmanuel ducron soir
jean sa liste à l'opinion vous traiter
entre autres les sujets liés au
transport gilles dansaert bienvenue soit
vous êtes journaliste directeur de moby
lettres site d'information dédiés aux
mobilités avec non visioconférence
j'accueille également pascal d onex qui
est directeur du projet tgv m pour la
sncf bonsoir bienvenue monsieur
dézoner et les tiac rue pas évidemment
l'éditorialiste de sens public qui est
resté à mes côtés la france a changé
j'ai envie de commencer avec ça la
france a changé en profondeur avec le tg
on le voit il vendôme alors évidemment
il ya le l'impact économique on en est
tous conscients vous l'aviez vécu aussi
en bretagne françoise gatel mais émanent
du crew là on dit tout le monde est
heureux mais combien ça a pu coûter une
gare tgv comme ça c'est la gare sept
gars là précisément je ne sais pas mais
on ne sait pas exactement ce qu'a coûté
le tgb j'ai posé la question à la sncf
récemment là et on m'a dit que c'était
impossible de savoir parce que ça s'est
étalée longtemps peut-être que vous le
savez gilles mais moi je ne le sais pas
et parce que bon et ça s'est construit
sur 40 ans ce réseau on on peut dire
quand même une chose c'est que un
kilomètre de tejari ça coûte en moyenne
20 millions d'euros voilà on sait déjà
ça 1 km coûte 20 millions parce qu'il
faut que ce soit très droite là donc il
ya beaucoup de travaux d'ingénierie
beaucoup d'ouvragés d'art sur le sur les
lignes de tgv donc en fait oui ça a
coûté ça a coûté cher il ya quoi de 1700
km de lignes à grande vitesse que si on
me parle beaucoup il faut multiplier et
puis il faut additionner pas c'est le
propre de du tgv c'est que c'est à la
fois l'infrastructure donc qui coûte
cher donc c'est des dizaines de
milliards et c'est aussi le matériel
roulant la signalisation des systèmes
teta donc c'est vrai que quand on arrive
quand même à la des sommes assez c'est
fantastique mais qu'il faut mettre en
rapport avec la création de valeur alors
juste et services rendus etc c'est ce
que j'avais dit enfin ceux qui la
trouvent à prendre l'exemple de la
bretagne où vas-tu en bretagne pour pour
avoir le tgv il a fallu quoi mobiliser
créer une sorte d'unanimité ce qui n'est
pas toujours facile en bretagne bonsoir
d'abord en bretagne la mobilisation
oecuméniques si je puis dire elle se
fait naturellement quand il ya une cause
majeure et là il s'agissait de
raccrocher en quelque sorte la bretagne
au dynamisme et au continent européen
parce que je rappelle que nous sommes
périphériques et péninsulaire et nous
n'avons rien oublié de la leçon du
général de gaulle qui continue en
montagne dans son grand discours de
campagne animée c'est bien sûr il faut
un grand plan routier sert quelque chose
qui eric la bretagne jusqu'au et donc la
bataille du tgv chinois était une
bataille conduite d'abord par le
président républicain de la région puis
jean yves le drian tous les élus tous
les acteurs économiques se sont battus
pour que ce tgv à yves chez nous parce
que alors combien ça coûte itunes qui
sûrement d'être anodine et élu local
longtemps je suis pas indifférente et en
même temps si je puis dire c'est qu'elle
est l'objectif à quoi ça sert quel effet
ça on peut faire un avant/après c'est à
dire que ç'a vraiment dynamiser
l'économie locale si on prend l'exemple
de rennes par exemple oui alors moi je
pense que d'abord le une à une des la
raison du tgv va moi ce que je vois pas
ce qu'on va nous parler du reste du
territoire est bien dit le confort la
lune c'était un défi un moment une
prouesse technologique et une volonté de
consolider une
organisation du pays sur des grands
centres économiques comme on a fait
après des métropoles donc ça participer
un peu de la même chose heinz a changé
la vie comme partout ces dix et nous on
peut parfois mettre une heure et demie
pour venir c'est là que les gens peuvent
habiter ils peuvent venir travailler à
paris on fait des choses on a tiers des
cadres enfin voilà ça raccroche à ce que
j'appelle la vie contemporaine
parlant d'un t on de deux ans qui
viennent s'installer parce qu'il ya le
tgv c'est ce que ce
portage à vendôme on est d'accord et des
cadres qui aujourd'hui se disent moi je
veux profiter d'un cadre de vie jeu par
exemple aller à saint malo voilà qui est
quand même une pépite bord de mer je
suis à 2h15 de tgv j aime travailler à
paris et tout ça s'était renforcée on
l'a vu par la crise sanitaire qui a
généré une sorte de migration vers vers
d'autres d'autres endroits que des pots
à condition qu'il y ait autour de la du
tgv d'état d'infrastructures et de
services extrêmement urbain il ya un
effet sur l'immobilier aussi il faut en
parler me louis borloo c'est le dernier
exemple en date la dernière ligne qui a
ouvert a effectivement ça fait flamber
les prix de l'immobilier à s'est
malicieusement la sncf dit que et sans
créer de la valeur et de la richesse
pour les habitants de bordeaux qui ont
vu leur patrimoine immobilier s'envoler
c'est très clairement ça a changé ça a
changé le visage de la de la france a
rétréci les distances c'est toujours
assez intéressant de regarder la carte
anamorphosée de la frein alors on à la
lumière
voilà la france n'a plus le même visage
ça c'est la france en la france verte
mais avant tout le monde la crise et la
france et j'ai vécu tant voilà et alors
ça crée aussi un peu une france à deux
vitesses est ce que vous diriez
s'agitent dans sa wii à deux voire trois
vitesses c'est à dire que il ya 40 ans
on demander à quelqu'un par y aller lyon
combien de kilomètres et aujourd'hui
tout le monde répond c'est deux heures
de tgv donc ça a complètement changé la
perception des espaces mais du coup les
villes et les territoires qui sont à
l'écart de ces dessertes tgv parce que
là on parle on confond un peu ligne à
grande vitesse et puis desserte lgv le
tgv il va jusqu'à quimper et à brest
mais il s'arrête à grande vitesse avec
moi mais cette france là
elle a le sentiment d'être un peu
déplacé et d'un point de vue économique
ça aussi des conséquences donc on a créé
quand même un déséquilibre tout
simplement parce que
du fait d'un certain nombre de choix
politiques et industriels au sein de la
sncf on a privilégié pour parler comme
les dirigeants dans le fond depuis
maintenant vingt ans on a parlé business
du tgv et on a oublié que la la
caractéristique d'un réseau ferroviaire
c'est que tout doit converger pour faire
que le voyageur a eu d'un point a à un
point b y est pas simplement d'une carte
tgv à une gare tgv et du coup là il ya
eu si on regarde le nombre de passagers
transportés sur la sur la durée il n'a
pas beaucoup augmenté le tgv a fait des
affaires mais on n'a pas eu une
croissance
du nombre de passagers dans le
ferroviaire français donc il s'agit
aujourd'hui on s'en aperçoit de
maintenant depuis 10 15 ans il s'agit
aujourd'hui de retisser un vrai réseau
ferroviaire articulé avec noeud
le transport régional les ter avec les
petites lignes et avec tous les nouveaux
mâts d'actifs ont reparlé évidemment de
ces petites lignes laetitia vous vouliez
l'histoire du tgv au des planes
puissance française pourquoi non quand
on parle des 40 ans du tgv effectivement
je pense immédiatement que c'était une
époque regretté que c'est le symbole de
la puissance de la vitesse de
l'innovation est évidemment c'était un
fleuron et qui permettait à la france de
rayonner sur la scène internationale or
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que nous
n'avons plus le monopole le leadership
que ça commence à s'ouvrir à la
concurrence et c'est un peu dans l'air
du temps malheureusement mais c'est une
petite musique qu'on commence à entendre
pour 2022 rendre à la france sa grandeur
mec france great games vous dire
je n'ai pas d'idée de slogans mais tous
les candidats déjà déclarés se sont
emparés de cette thématique là est
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron qui célèbre
le tgv m on en parlera tout à l'heure
les entendre écouter le champ lexical
qui l'utilisent il répète le mot de
génie français parce qu'il sait très
bien que healy à cette perception est
factuellement aussi c'est vérifiable
d'une perte voilà du rayonnement
français de la puissance française et
donc une certaine fierté finalement et
sa liberté là je pense que ce sera au
coeur de 2022 ray mais alors parce
qu'elle des zones et vous nous écoutez
depuis tout à l'heure vous vous
travaillez donc sur vous êtes le
directeur même de ce projet tgv m pour
la sncf et vous allez nous dire qu'il
est innovant évidemment en quoi il est
innovant
du mal à nous dire le contraire
effectivement la mecque que
[Musique]
parce que ça faisait à peu près 25 ans
depuis la mise en route des rames tgv
duplex qui avait pas eu un grand niveau
d'innovation donc on a décidé de partir
d'une feuille blanche et de se donner
des objectifs assez fort effectivement
pour remettre ce train encore plus dans
la compétition ils permettent à essayer
d'être encore plus dans la compétition
transports on a travaillé sur des
objectifs de réduction du coût déjà du
train ils sont du coup de maintenance de
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
l'amélioration du confort digital à bord
de deux fonctions assez technique mais
tout ça c'est pour vraiment fournir sncf
un outil dans la compétition qui
permettra on l'espère aussi alstom de
revenir vers la compétition du train à
grande vitesse
on va regarder quelques grandes dates du
tgv on en a choisi quatre les premières
études c'est intéressant sur le
processus industriel et sur l'engagement
d'un état quand on décide de se lancer
dans un projet comme ça première étude
c'est 1966 premier prototype
1971 l'inauguration du tgv paris-lyon
gelé vite alors 81 94 premières aux
stars paris/londres pascal des zones et
vous on vous dit qu'on sort d'une
période un peu d'endormissement en fait
si je comprends bien si on n'avait pas
inventé grand chose
belle endormie mais une très belle
endormie
ça permet de transporter tous les jours
des gens en sécurité avec un niveau de
confort et de la réplique et messieurs
que quelque part il fallait se remettre
sur la table avec de nouveaux objectifs
on a ses objectifs environnementaux
c'est à dire que l'objectif de 116 quand
même dû transporter des gens la sécurité
mais aussi
être chaque jour plus vert donc
il a fallu travailler notamment sur la
baisse de la consommation d'énergie
parce que c'est un sujet très important
à la fois parce que qui dit consommation
dini potentiellement co2 et puis autre
sujet on le voit maintenant c'est qu'ils
des consommations d'énergie qui
potentiellement augmentation des coûts
parce que vous savez qu'à un moment
donné l'énergie risque de plus en plus
cher donc oui dormi c'est une très très
belle endormie ça aurait pu durer encore
longtemps comme ça mais on s'est dit
voilà un moment il faut faire un effort
il faut repartir d'une feuille blanche
aussi de refaire quelque chose restez
avec nous parce qu'elle dézoner jeu
jours donnera la parole tout à l'heure
ça vous faisait réagir manuel du cros ce
que nous disait le directeur du projet
parce que le tgv était peut-être une
belle endormie mais il a quand même 7 ce
fantastique avantage dans l'époque
convient c'est que c'est un train qui
roule avec de l'énergie nucléaire il
faut pas oublier que le développement du
tgv c'est aussi lié au développement du
club de l'énergie nucléaire en france
donc le bilan carbone du tgv il est déjà
très bon il sera face et vous voilà
c'est un bilan carbone très bon
consommer ou 20 % d'énergie en moins sur
le nouveau tgv m qu'elles sont et où
tout allonge étouffante au héros
dynamique c'est encore mieux mais on
oublie ça et je pense que dans la
nouvelle donne énergétique c'est-à-dire
cette espèce de volonté passer en
dessous 50% d'énergie nucléaire on
devrait pas oublier que notre réseau de
transport on repose sur cette énergie
nucléaire qui
abandonnée et ben oui qui le rend qui le
rend fiable qui le rend abordable et qui
le rend très économe en co2 voilà
c'était il était très précurseur de ce
point de vue là en fait il ya eu une
période excusez moi il ya une période
entre la fin de la course à la vitesse
avec le record de 574 km heure en 2007
et là on s'est dit est ce qu'on va aller
plus loin et la décision a été prise de
ne pas monter à 360 en qu'en vitesse
commerciale donc là on dit stop c'est
fini la course à la vie se laisse trois
notre cher 120 la vitesse ont créé
environ 320 donc la stoppe la course à
la vitesse et du coup qu'est ce qu'on
fait et il a fallu un certain temps
avant de dire la priorité maintenant est
effectivement sur du qualitatif le
confort l'énergie etc il a fallu ce
temps pourrait relancer le tgv alors
c'est intéressant je vous donne la
parole tout de suite force
gatel mais je voudrais qu'on écoute le
patron de la sncf sur ce sur ce thème
c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que la
vitesse n'est plus prioritaire
maintenant c'est l'écologie qu'il faut
mettre en avant jean pierre farandou
tout de suite il faut à nouveau tgv on
est déjà cette génération dans la hâte
de tgv là c'est la huitième la 8ème
c'est plus la vitesse maintenant on est
à 320 kilomètres heure on cherche pas à
aller encore plus vite c'est déjà pas
mal ou on avale les kilomètres a320 les
enjeux c'est quoi c'est l'écologie la
protection de la planète ce nouveau
trajet tgv aura une empreinte carbone
réduit de 30 % ic au franc parler par le
par le choix des matériaux y sera moins
lourd oui part l'aérodynamisme
oui mais voilà donc il a une empreinte
carbone bien meilleure il concerne pas
moins d'énergie voilà on a ce souci
effectivement que l'aisne pas carbone
soit plus bas et on le rappelle tout ça
c'est de l'électricité décarbonée on a
la chance en france bien sûr d'avoir une
électricité qui est décarbonée donc on
va très bien même par carbone qui était
déjà faible ils seront encore plus
faibles oui et donc on retrouve
l'argument de serre que ça vous sur le
maintien d'une énergie décarbonée donc
d'un parc nucléaire digne de ce nom oui
je partage et moi je suis très heureuse
de rappel que vous avez fait parce qu'on
a parfois on entend parfois dépenser
très côte sur l'obsession qui est
légitime de choses plus durable et plus
écologique mais il faut pas rappelé
enfin il faut rappeler faut surtout pas
oublier que sans énergie nucléaire on
n'atteindra pas un autre objectif est
qu'il ya un mix énergétique où je pense
que le nucléaire a toute sa place il en
était question hier hier au sénat moi je
je je pense que il y a une idée très
intéressante qui est de redonner de la
fierté à la france on est tous fiers on
a connu des fiertés dans les salles donc
moi je trouve ça c'est génial ça peut
mobiliser les gens cette envie d'être
propre et flück et frugale en termes
d'énergie s'est pas fait mais si on veut
être vert écologique faudrait pas
oublier que c'est une grande partie du
territoire français
qui doit se déplacer bon allez
travailler qui n'est pas connecté à ses
grandes artères et si on veut aussi
diminuer le bilan carbone c'est en
diminuant lusage de la voiture et moi je
crois que la circulation en france c'est
comme la circulation dans un corps
toutes les parties doivent être
irriguées et que je pense que des lignes
ferroviaires qu'on appelle des petits
délits sont plutôt des lignes du
quotidien mais elles sont essentielles
pour permettre de se connecter c'est
comme ça qu'on doit le faire et puis je
pense qu'il faut pas oublier la crise
des gilet jaune a quand même donné des
leçons sur ce sentiment d'abandon et
c'est pourquoi au sénat la loi cadre et
nous on soutient le transfert aux
régions qui sont n'occuperont beaucoup
mieux se sait beaucoup un plan d'attaqué
impulseront de de la résurrection des
petites lignes ferroviaires alors
justement va parler des petites lignes
tout de suite avec marion vi e mario
vous pouvez nous rejoindre sur le
plateau de sens public re bonsoir
effectivement fait un petit coup d'oeil
dans le rétroviseur on l'a évoqué mais
rapidement ce démon par le soin de tout
tgv effectivement un développement qui
se fait au détriment des petits bouts
effectivement puisque passée l'euphorie
suite à l'arrivée du tgv le
désenclavement annoncé à des territoires
n'a pas été au rendez vous pour tous le
développement des lignes à grande
vitesse vers les métropoles s'est fait
aux dépens des lignes régionales et en
plus particulier de celles qu'on classe
syfy et qu'on qualifie de petites lignes
qui représentent 17 % des trains
régionaux et qui desservent des
territoires ruraux et des villes
moyennes je pense par exemple à la ligne
entre périgueux et agen ou encore dans
le cantal entre aurillac et figeac
depuis les années 80 plusieurs rapports
font état d'un sous investissement
chronique et quelques chiffres en guise
de preuve de 30 mille kilomètres de
petites lignes au début du 20e siècle on
est passé aujourd'hui à 9000 des lignes
qui sont électrifiés seulement à hauteur
de 20 % elles sont vieillissantes elles
sont mal entretenus et des retards sont
importants autant d'éléments qui
dissuade les voyageurs qui se reportent
vers les voitures conséquence ces
petites lignes accueille aujourd'hui
deux pour cent des voyageurs et 40 % du
réseau est menacée de fermeture alors la
fermeture c'est justement ce que
préconise le rapport spinetta en étant
2018 oui au motif qu'elle n'était plus
rentable et générer trop de dépenses
rapport avait fait bondir les élus
locaux et en particulier les sénateurs
pour qui ces lignes sont essentielles à
l'équilibré au dynamisme et à
l'attractivité des territoires se sont
comme ils le disent en quelque sorte des
lignes de vie conséquence le
gouvernement abandonne cette idée et
opte pour une stratégie de
réinvestissement qui a un coût il a été
estimé à 7,6 milliards d'euros sur dix
ans l'état commencent à investir il
n'est pas le seul la loi cadet de
décentralisation va permettre aux
régions de devenir propriétaire des
infrastructures et de gérer la mobilité
sur leur territoire comme elle le
souhaite mais d'autres acteurs
apparaissent également et je vous
propose d'écouter à ce sujet le sénateur
des alpes-maritimes philippe tabarot
c'est l'ancien conseiller régional en
charge des transports en région paca
il ya d'autres possibilités aussi qu'ils
sont des coopératives qui commencent à
se créer dans notre pays pour exploiter
ces lignes je pense notamment à rail cup
qui a eu toutes les autorisations
nécessaires pour pouvoir le faire et
troisième possibilité l'ouverture à la
concurrence à la différence de ce que
certains disent l'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est pas la fin des petites
lignes ferroviaires ça peut être une
nouvelle vie pour les lignes
ferroviaires je pense notamment à la
région de gentes qui ouvre son réseau à
la concurrence et qui dit aux opérateurs
allez sur les lignes qui sont fermées
aujourd'hui et essayer de nous ré ouvrir
ces petits films ferroviaire on vous
suit si c'est le cas donc autant
d'éléments qui permet non effectivement
peut-être de sauver une partie de ces
petites lignes ferroviaires qui ont
aujourd'hui toute leur place à l'heure
du réchauffement climatique et où l'on
nous ensuite pardon à abandonner la
voiture au profit du train merci marion
pour toutes ces précisions évidemment ça
ouvre pas mal de deux thèmes en parlera
de l'ouverture à la concurrence tout à
l'heure peut-être d'abord le
sous-investissement emmanuel ducrocq je
me tourne vers vers vous il a été c'est
un choix politique tout simplement c'est
qu'on a vérifié ses lignes au profit du
tgv ouais je sais pas si ça a été un
vrai choix mais ils y ont volé
en tous cas commandent il ya eu beaucoup
le tgv c'est la france ça veut dire ça
c'est l'image de la france c'est à dire
que on a été tiraillé avec cette
histoire de tgv entre ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire rationnellement et
industriellement et puis ce qu'on a fait
en tenant compte des élus locaux des
collectivités territoriales des
baronnies qui tous voulaient leur
morceau de kg vs cas quand même
considérablement alourdi les coûts et
donc en fait on a tous voila la france a
été tiraillé entre ses deux ces deux
pôles disons et on n'a pas toujours été
très rationnel dans l' usage qu'on a
fait du développement des lignes tgv et
oui clairement le réseau français est
vieillissant enfin il l'était il avait
30 ans de moyenne d'âge ce qui est assez
vieux en europe au moment où on a
commencé à parler de la réforme de la
sncf donc là clairement maintenant les
moyens sont mis sur l'entretien du
réseau il est plus que temps de le faire
parce que vraiment ça craque et d'
absolument partout mais
on a choisi c'est à dire que pour le
coup le tgv risque d'être un peu sur
pause un moment il ya des petits
morceaux de lignes qui vont être un peu
refait mais clairement on a basculé vers
ont trouvé autre chose on est reparti
vers quelque chose de plus local gilles
dans ça on ne peut pas faire les deux en
même temps c'est moi c'est ce que
j'entends dans ce que dit mme adèle du
coup c'est en termes de d'investissement
de financement on peut pas continuer de
mettre le paquet sur le tgv et
redévelopper ou rebooster les petites
lignes en tout cas l'état a décidé de ne
pas faire les deux en même temps
d'accord autant l'argent magie tout
comme
on n'a pas fait et pour ne pas nourrir
un éventuel complot anti rural la
conséquence du tout tgv ça s'est senti
aussi dans les agglomérations c'est à
dire les chiffres de fréquentation des
lignes de banlieue dans les gants de 11
métropoles paris évidemment mais aussi
d'autres n'ont pas été suivies d'un
entretien d'un investissement à la
hauteur donc on a aujourd'hui des crises
majeures dans des rer francilien mais
aussi dans les grandes métropoles parce
qu'on n'a pas non plus investi dans ces
lignes là donc c'est tout tout le réseau
ferroviaire qui était sous investis et
quand emmanuel macron le 1er juillet
2010 est donc juste après son élection
dit à rennes moi maintenant on va
privilégier tour du quotidien on arrête
le tgv bon on a arrêté le tgv on n'a pas
vraiment beaucoup réinvesti sur les
transports du quotidien et quatre ans
après parce que les élections arrivent
alors tout d'un coup il faut remettre du
tgv parce que c'est la grandeur de la
france c'est gribouille c'est gribouille
depuis 20 ans avec l'inauguration
effectivement ou le dévoilement du du
tgm on va écouter tient emmanuel macron
ce jour là
nous avons ainsi réengagés une politique
d'investissement relancer le train de
nuit est lancée en février 2020 le
fameux plan petite ligne
appelée de leurs voeux par tant de nos
élus locaux et
nos parlementaires ici présent tout ce
qui a été mis en oeuvre depuis quatre
ans a permis
de protéger parfois de réparer de
commencer à ré envisager l'avenir au
lard et envisager l'avenir avec le ce ce
tgv
derrière lui le travail ne vaut pas ça
me fait pas rire
non ré envisager l'avenir avec le
traduit peut-être je ne sais pas je
connais pas l'alimentation donc
elle est basse c'est ce que je vais vous
demander madame est ce que si on met un
peu voilà on développe à nouveau ces
petites lignes auquel vous êtes attaché
est ce que la fréquentation va suivre
parce que on voit bien que vous parliez
de la crise et gilet jaune l'usagé de la
voiture est encore primordial dans pour
la plupart des français donc comment on
fait basculer d'un modèle à l'autre
est-ce que la ligne quel usage on
pourrait faire un parallèle avec les les
pistes cyclables dans les villes à
partir ils sont plus faciles d'accès ya
plus de vélos dessus donc est ce que la
ligne geste je pense qu'il ya aussi
j'aurais répondre à la crise sont
présentées à moi je n'ai jamais vu un
industriel est monomaniaque sur un
investissement c'est à dire il va
développer quelque chose d'exceptionnel
mais parallèlement à ça il va prendre le
soin en bon gestionnaire d'entretenir
des choses qui à un moment vous coûter
très cher si on ne fait pas donc chez ac
aillerie qu'on sacrifie tout autant
j'évite tout en reconnaissant son amante
chaussée ubs quoi bon petit que ces
français ensuite alors est-ce que la
ligne créé l' usage ou lusage créé la
ligne je ne sais pas en tout cas si on
on réagit où on pense en matière de
société d' équilibre territorial de
cohésion sans fin choix de concentration
d'activités des gens dans les grandes
villes avec tous les problèmes que sa
peau sur cher immobilière risques
sociaux et où sont ceux dits on peut
avoir une sorte d'âme un tueur urbanac
des très grandes villes des villes
moyennes et des petites villes et vous
développerez des entreprises des
services de la médecine dans les villes
moyennes si vous vd ligne connexes à
sept grandes articulations qui le tgv
alors que le métro alors le métro est
très utilisé mais le métro est ce qu'il
est rentable jédir le transport ne
serait jamais rentables
vont investir dans ces petites lignes je
mets des guillemets quitte à ce que ce
soit pas rentable non non alors je vais
dire ça oui excusez moi je me suis mal
exprimé chez baader que les régions
elles vont trouver très à la mode de
faire ça parce que ces merdes non non
les rays les régions sont aussi des
gestionnaires intentions mais on regarde
et cité l'exemple de la ligne agen je ne
sais plus pour aller d'âge je ne suis
plus qu'à lille c'est très compliqué
comme suit à raison on raisonne en temps
quand vous n'avez pas d'axé routier
figeac s'est elle voilà
pour développer figeac oy a créé des
centralités qui font qu'il ya moins de
gens désespérés dans les territoires moi
je pense qu'il faut se réarmer mais
d'une manière raisonnable moi je dis pas
qu'il faut voir toutes les lignes
partout de faire 50 milliards mais il
faut d'abord avoir un projet
les mobilités c'est au service d'un
projet c'est quoi qui on veut déplacer
mais c'est certain que la mère de
famille qui a deux enfants en bas âge
qui doit aller travailler va pas prendre
le train le matin quand même prend pas
le bus ça dépend si les gens prendront
leur voiture ton qu'on leur offre pas
d'autre solution mois donc faut trouver
quelque chose d'acceptable mais
d'ambitieux et est-ce que je m'en sers
le fait de fermer les petites mines
comme le préconisait le rapport spinetta
en 2010 est encore envisageable d'après
ou est-ce que ça a été mis de côté non
il ya des petits signes qui vont être
fermés parce qu'il ya des meetings qui
ne desservent aucune zone d'habitation
ni aucune zone économistes qui sont
vraiment il y aurait éventuellement un
peu de tourisme et s'il n'y a pas de
projet autant les fermer et faut parer
l'offre open mais il ya eu il y en a
d'autres qui pourraient mais qui
revitalise et on le voit il ya des cas
concrets en france comme dans nos pays
voisins qui retrouve une certaine
vitalité mais on peut faut pas faire les
choses à moitié pendant longtemps on a
fait les choses à moitié et à dire que
effectivement un conseil régional a mis
beaucoup d'argent ou pour rénover une
petite ligne mais avec peu de fréquences
c'est à dire si on met quatre jours
correspond pas au rythme sociaux donc
faut pas faire des choses à moitié en
même temps tout ça et de l'économie
subventionnés en exploitation c'est à
dire que oui grosso modo l'usagé paye
30% du prix du voyage aussi bien en
train que des transports publics or
mille tgv qui est le seul où l'usager
paie 100 % du coût d'exploitation donc
la différence allait vraiment là le
transport du quotidien est
considérablement subventionné
oui je voudrais revenir sur le notion
d'innovation et je reviens vers pascal
des zones et qui est avec nous en
visioconférence je vous demander de nous
décrire un peu ce tgv m quand même pour
conclure parce que voilà ça nous
projette dans notre futur moyen de
transport mais est ce qu'il ya de
l'innovation sur les petites lignes
aussi
gérer
l'innovation
il ya pas mal de projets
c'est pas mon domaine de spécialité mais
sur des trains dits légers sur des
choses effectivement
[Musique]
et soit une petite y ait quelque chose
d'assez particulier il faut ce qu'on
appelle de l'armement de voix c'est à
dire qu'il faut que la voie soit robuste
cetera donc vous travaillez tout ça les
systèmes de de signalisation sur le côté
coûte extrêmement cher donc est-ce qu'on
peut développer et ça existe maintenant
des systèmes de signalisation plus léger
mais qui offre une sécurité toute aussi
aux dons qui lui sur les petites lignes
il ya plein plein d'innovations après ça
a été dit ce sont des décisions locales
que ce serait fou d'autres peuvent
accompagner mais effectivement c'est des
moyens à mettre
ses du service public donc subventionné
mais il ya plein de d'innovation
possible l'essentiel aujourd'hui par son
service recherche innovation justement
est en train de travailler sur des
solutions pour faire des trains beaucoup
plus léger parce que c'est une
exploitation plus léger tout en
garantissant un très haut niveau de
sécurité faites-nous monter à bord de ce
tgv m l'
île aux patients encore mais j'ai s'il
vous fait rêver de danse et rend donc la
particularité de ce train c'est que on a
dit travailler sur la partie
environnementale
donc
consommation d'énergie recyclabilité des
matériaux qualité de l'air avant du
train quand on a lancé notre on n'avait
pas imaginé que vous voulez mettre sur
le système de filtration d'air a été
très si important aujourd'hui avec la
crise sanitaire on va travailler sur
l'accessibilité donc ça sera le premier
tgv en france qui permettra à des
personnes en fauteuil roulant de rentrer
en toute autonomie parce que offrir un
service où les gens sont accompagnés
c'est bien c'est que les personnes en
fauteuil ou mans cherche aussi à un
certain degré d'autonomie on va
travailler sur
d'ici quelques mois
une grande grande innovation sur la
partie restauration et sur la partie
espace détente avec quelque chose qui ne
s'est jamais tu restes on
s'appelle un teaser ça en bon français
combien ça coûte genre
je suis pas sûr que c'est vrai que le
prix du billet je suis pas sûr que
pascal des zones et peut déjà répondre à
la question puisqu'il est prévu pour
quand ce tgv m au nom du pays je peux
répondre partiellement
comme je lis 10 pts heures quand on a
lancé ce projet donc le dit l'idée de
base est de 2014 mouvement
c'est en marketing on a des produits qui
évolue quand un produit devient mature
les gens cherchent toujours à ce que son
prix baisse
et léonce et de rejeter sur la même idée
sûreté du mc cain en gros deux autres il
fallait que le prix baisse donc ce train
coûte à l'achat 20% moins cher
fonctions identiques que les anciens tgv
donc
quand on parle de baisser la
consommation d'énergie de baisser le
coût de maintenance de 30% et c'est bien
sûr que le côté économique et pris en
charge en même temps que le côté
environnemental parce que moi la
maintenance coûte cher c'est à dire en
gel de pièces et en fait c'est tout tout
tout vent se tenir à la fois faire
quelque chose de plus frugale d'un point
de vue technique mais tout aussi robuste
travailler sur le coup travailler sur
l'environnement terre après qu'elle sera
bien sûr le lier vous verrez comment ça
se passera aspord plat dans le contexte
du coût de l'énergie du coût des sillons
du coup de brut chose et voilà mais mes
deux bases le tgv n a été étudié pour
servir au mieux le côté économique de
l'exploitation d'une bourde à grande
vitesse merci pascal des zones et ça
vous fait réagir gym danse a beaucoup ri
en fait la sncf et chalenge et sur le
confort et les services et sur le prix
par ses futurs concurrents il ya une
ouverture et en italie que l'arrivée la
concurrence a débouché sur des trains où
il y avait trois quatre classes
différentes qui correspondent à des
usages différents dans le train pour les
hommes et les femmes d'affaires pour les
familles pour des étudiants c'est là
donc donc là il ya un challenge à
améliorer le confort et de service et
puis le prix
dire que on est aujourd'hui dans un
monde de concurrence et donc même si les
péages sont trop élevés et là il faut
interroger quand même la politique de
l'état français qui continuent à être
malthusien avec des péages élevé au lieu
de jouer une baisse des péages que
l'europe et h c'est pas les péages que
nous mais en voiture a laissé des péages
que paye la compagnie ferroviaire au
gestionnaire du réseau donc si on les
baisse on peut encourager plus de trains
parce qu'il faut bien dire aujourd'hui
que ya assez peu de français qui
utilisent le train par rapport à son
potentiel si on compare par rapport au
japon par rapport même en italie on a
produit 7 90% en quelques années sur
l'usagé du train donc la sncf et
chalenge et donc tout l'intérêt d'élise
avait prochaine c'est de voir les
différentes services que vous proposez
les uns et les autres de confort et puis
le prix parce que il faut abaisser comme
le disait le responsable du tgv m pour
abaisser le point mort pour faire en
sorte que les français reviennent pas
vers le train de façon plus massif les
modèles du crawl à l'avenir du tgv on va
terminer là dessus il va être donc
bousculer on l'a bien compris par
l'ouverture à la concurrence en revanche
c'est quand même un atout majeur c'est
la limitation des usages de l'avion le
fait de deux du pouvoir prendre l'avion
pour surtout instance sur une distance
supérieure à 2 heures 30 donc ça c'est
quand même un atout pour le tgv
actuelles ou sur d'éventuelles nouvelles
lignes qui pourrait ouvrir oui ça cccc
c'est évident que c'est un atout pour le
tgv ça reste quand même quelque chose
d'absolument central dans la
structuration économique de la sncf
c'est ce qui fait l'essentiel de ses
bénéfices si la sncf ne perd pas
d'argent enfin plus en tout cas c'est
parce que le tgv est rentable à l'ina
plus rentable de france et lyon paris
lyon s'incline 1 l et c'est une pour ma
place est une machine à cash en sait un
peu triviale mais oui
dans la mesure où on arrive avec de
l'innovation à faire baisser encore les
coûts d'exploitation le tgv c'est aussi
un pilier financier d'avenir pour la
sncf et ça ça va passer par plusieurs
choses dont tu vas y voilà comment est
ce qu'on fait plus de services pour que
les gens acceptent de payer des billets
plus chers comment aussi est-ce qu'on
fiabilise les temps de transport et ça
ça dépend de la fiabilité du réseau qui
ont état d'entretien etc et puis il va y
avoir tout ce qui va se passer
maintenant sur comment est ce qu'on fait
de la signalisation beaucoup plus
connectés en fait on a maintenant on va
pouvoir faire de la de là comment dire
la signalisation beaucoup plus fine en
connectant les ram etc et en utilisant
moins des tronçons si j'ai bien compris
enfin voilà pour pouvoir aussi augmenter
les cadences et économe et donc tout ça
ben voilà ça va faire baisser les coûts
d'exploitation et donc voilà il a un bel
avenir merci
les bacs étaient passionnants voilà
c'est la fin de ce sens public je vous
donne rendez-vous lundi demain demain 8
oriane mansigné reçoit laurent saint
martin le député les royaumes du val de
marne qui est le rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée bonne soirée merci
à toutes et à tous